by news grande nouvelle vous savez il ya
toujours des rumeurs sur la chaîne parce
que je trouve intéressant de parler de
ces rumeurs parce qu'elles permettent de
sentir un peu les tendances de voir ce
qui va arriver
certaines s'avèrent vraies et au final
on voit que les rumeurs étaient avérés
et qu'on retrouve ses produits sa
marchette
et puis des fois c'est un faux complet
ça marche pas mais en attendant était ce
qui est super pertinent est super
intéressant c'est d'essayer de sentir un
petit peu de marche et de comprendre ce
qui va se passer de voir les enjeux et
de voir comment se positionnent les
marques les unes par rapport aux autres
pour répondre à des lancements de
produits de concurrents devront adapter
leurs gardes
ça c'est génial et aujourd'hui on va
parler de samsung galaxy s 10 qui va
sortir d'ici quelques grands mois
puisque ce sera en début 2010
et vous allez voir vous allez voir on
n'est pas au bout de nos surprises
[Musique]
très grand fan de samsung parce que je
trouve que samsung fait vraiment des
produits qui sont de super bonne qualité
il arrive toujours à innover il succombe
pas aux tendances pour l'instant qu'on
ne soit pas succomber à la fameuse
encoches il ya une rumeur il ya quelques
temps d'ailleurs j'en avais déjà parlé
qui faisait état d'une potentielle
arrivée de l'encoche sur le samsung
galaxy 10 pour l'instant pas trop
d'infos là tu donc on garde un peu de
côté l'info dont je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui est vraiment intéressante
parce que elle vient de l'analyste
starmine chico musicaux s'était collé
pour les prédictions très juste
concernant apple
il est donc aujourd'hui en analyse star
est une feuille analyse très
intéressante pour ce samsung galaxy s 10
si vous avez suivi précédente vidéo
j'ai déjà parlé de michiko plusieurs
fois et notamment de sa fameuse
prédiction que tout le monde reprend
pour cette fin d'année pour apple il
annonce effectivement l'arrivée de trois
nouveaux iphone pour cette fin d'année
et c'est justement là que c'est
intéressant parce que ils annoncent pont
samsung l'arrivée de trois nouveaux
samsung galaxy s 10 en début d'année
prochaine
[Musique]
c'est à dire que samsung s'adapterait
réellement à la proposition d'apple
si c'est vrai et c'est là que c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est à dire si ça
me son travail vraiment sur trois
nouveaux samsung galaxy s 10 ça veut
dire qu'ils prennent vraiment très au
sérieux les prédictions de mini chico
dès lors qu'un industriel vadapter saga
mais il a commencé à travailler sur
trois nouveaux modèles alors que les
modèles des concurrents sont encore
sortis c'est quand même dingue ou alors
ça veut dire qu'il ya de l'espionnage
industriel est que samsung c'est déjà ce
que apple a dans les cartons
c'est intéressant ou alors ça veut dire
que apple et samsung communiquent entre
eux qu acteur ça tu vas faire ça mais ça
ça me paraît un petit peu moins
plausible en attendant c'est la
prédiction 2006 pau trois nouveaux
samsung galaxy s 10 dès 2019
attendez si quelques jours l'annoncé
faite par samsung le galaxy note 9 qui
devrait déjà être un modèle intéressant
qui serait plus une évolution du notw
itunes grande révolution qui sera un
petit peu le corollaire de l'évolution
du s suit os9 légaux sont d'une haute
suite aux notes 9 pour ça on en reparle
d'ici quelques temps donc je vous invite
à rester connectés et à vous abonner
mais ce galaxy s 10 peut vraiment être
intéressant et en plusieurs fois
on aurait donc trois nouveaux formats
d'écran un écran de 5,8 pouces un écran
de 6,1 pouces et un écran de 6,4 pousse
tous ces écrans ce n'est sur des écrans
super amoled comme le fait
habituellement samsung faut savoir que
samsung de par sa filiale samsung
display y fabrique directement ses
écrans donc on est sûr qu'ils vont pas
nous coller des écrans lcd là dessus et
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
les deux modèles les plus grands le 6,1
pouces et 6 24 pouces aurait une
nouvelle technologie que samsung mais
très dense et smartphones c'est à dire
un lecteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée
directement à l'écran
[Musique]
déjà sur d'autres smartphones seront sur
le marché n'est pour l'instant pas sur
les produits de la marque sud-coréenne
se serait d'ailleurs leur axe de
communication pour la rentrée plus de
sécurité avec cette nouvelle technologie
sas en quelque sorte une réponse à apple
par rapport à son fils il dit le capteur
d'empreintes digitales sous l'écran pour
être plus sécurisé vous n'auriez qu'à
prendre votre smartphone et dès que vous
le prenez en main il reconnaît votre
empreinte digitale
pas besoin de le regarder même si
effectivement fait s'est dit extrêmement
rapide on attrape son téléphone il est
déjà déverrouiller alors qu'on l'a même
pas mis devant notre visage dont quelque
chose encore plus rapide que faith haïti
par contre le modèle le plus petit le 5
2 8 pouces lui n'aurait pas de capteur
d'empreintes digitales directement
intégré à l'écran ils vont être
probablement toujours faith and lobe qui
n'est pas le plus sécurisé il y aurait
pas de 14 ans empreintes digitales au
dos mais son côté comment on peut
retrouver chez sonic sur le sony xperia
x10 permettrait d'avoir un modèle un peu
différent surtout ça coûterait beaucoup
moins cher à samsung a fabriquée que
d'intégrer capteur d'empreintes
digitales directement à l'écran l'année
prochaine également samsung d'autres et
son modèle le plus grand d'un double
capteur photo d'un double module photo
serait donc le modèle doté d'un écran de
6,4 pousse donc double module photo
l'arrière et un peu plus boosté en ram
s'est rendu au samsung galaxy s 10
devrait être présenté au mwc à barcelone
comme samsung l'a fait l'année dernière
pour la présentation du galaxy s 9
à noter qu'à une autre rumeur que cette
fois ci n'est pas une prédiction 2006
pau c'est une rumeur qui fait état de
cinq caméras directement sur ce galaxy s
10 vous aurez donc trois caméras à
l'arrière de caméras à l'avant une
première caméra à l'arrière qui serait
une caméra un peu classique une deuxième
caméra qui serait un tel objectif pour
les faits évoqués et pour pouvoir aller
zoomer dans vos images sans perdre en
qualité et un troisième qui serait un
grand-angle vous auriez donc de plus
grandes possibilités et à l'avant vous
auriez deux caméras pour avoir un vrai
effet boké donc ça ça pourrait être
plutôt cool également voilà un peu pour
ces nouveautés toutes ces infos toutes
ces rumeurs toute cette ambiance tout ce
qu'on peut se sentir et tout ce qu'on
peut voir sur ce futur samsung galaxy s
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous vous attendez ce modèle
avec impatience tous les deux ans
samsung sort un modèle vraiment innovant
on a eu un bruit et changement avec
l'écran infiniti et le samsung galaxy et
suite on a vu que ce s9 même si on a une
lentille ouverture variable n'est jamais
qu'une évolution du et suite même si
c'est une évolution intéressante au
niveau de la photo est là
vidéo like le s10 on devrait avoir de
vrais changements des choses très
significatif extrêmement intéressante
donc dites moi vous en commentaire ce
que vous attendez qu'est ce qui pourrait
vous intéresser par rapport à la
concurrence par rapport à ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui sur le marché qu'est ce que
vous voudriez avoir 66 galaxy s 10 est
ce que vous voudriez avoir un écran d'un
seul et grand tenant comme se retrouver
sur le niveau d'aix ou alors sur l'eau
potable x est-ce que contrario vous
louez toujours une barre sur le haut une
barre sur le bas est ce que vous voulez
une encoche qu'est ce que vous voudriez
sans ce samsung galaxy s disent vous ne
marquez tout ça en commentaire comme
d'habitude vous avez tant décédé jolie
pousse à rester connectés à vous abonner
parce que vous allez voir on va toujours
pareil plus de teck a plein de choses à
dire il ya plein de nouveautés plein de
choses qui arrivent dans les temps à
venir
donc on reste connectés une cigogne
merci à vous soyez sages vous embrasse
n'oublie pas vu le film ayant et à très
bientôt
[Musique]